what's the deal with airplane peanuts
oh i never told you the end of that oh
sorry so no i took that bag of mushrooms
to that party
right and a bunch of people ate them
who'd never had them before
uh-oh and then we played a game of go
hide-and-go-seek right i was like oh no
dude you hide in another dimension i was
like
i'll count you guys go hide right oh no
and i never went to [ __ ] look for it
that was the in the head bro i never
seen one dude this boy timothy i've
never seen that dude again
all i do is i listen i watch the news
once every two weeks i'm like
mascara no mess seal mask all right mask
that's all i give a [ __ ] about
i don't care but even they say you
shouldn't wear a mask unless you're
treating a coronavirus patient the world
health organization
they didn't say that initially they
didn't say it initially no they didn't
they did and then it gradually then it
grabbed and then wait wait wait and then
everybody wore the [ __ ] masks
this is like rollerblading everybody
[ __ ] rollerbladed and then there was
that one [ __ ] homophobic joke and
then everybody acted like they never did
it
and then a hundred million [ __ ]
rollerblades got thrown into the [ __ ]
ocean
we all wore math and then all of a
sudden people are [ __ ] sitting there
what you don't have the body type for it
dude your [ __ ] knuckles would scrape
on the ground
even with that extra two inches
play this because 24 things nobody is
better at than trump
nobody can do it like me nobody nobody
can do it like that
honestly nobody's stronger than me
nobody has better choice than i do
there's nobody
better or better at the military than i
am nobody loves the bible more than i do
nobody builds walls better than me
nobody's better
to people with disabilities than me
nobody's fighting for the veterans like
i'm fighting for them
there's nobody that's done so much for
equality as i have there's nobody more
pro-israel than i am there's
nobody more conservative than me there
is nobody that respects women more than
i don't know
he would be tougher on isis
donald trump nobody's ever had crowds
like trump has had
there's nobody that understands he's in
australia yeah he's on
tour right now and he goes yeah this
morning
yeah man got a koala come come to the
hotel and i went
oh [ __ ] man those things have uh
chlamydia so make sure you wash your
hands
and he goes [ __ ] i have some things too
he better wash his hands
hotel that's so theo
wings must be done with blue cheese blue
cheese yeah like the way they invented
in buffalo new york if you're gonna do
something rich
do it original you're gonna show up with
that ranch that smells like somebody's
ass give a snap
ranch is starting to replace ketchup
yeah that's good if you're a [ __ ]
hillbilly
and you want to taste the ass in your
mouth oh [ __ ] day
i hate that [ __ ] red [ __ ] don't put
it close to me don't put it around me
it's either blue cheese with wings and
go [ __ ] your mother that's the next
shirt all right
please
you're gonna give me a [ __ ] uh ranch
was like we should do a flamethrower
so we does anybody tell you no does
anybody go elon um
maybe for yourself but selling a
flamethrower the liabilities all the
people you're selling this device to
what kind of unhinged people are going
to be buying a flamethrower in the first
place do we really want to connect
ourselves
to all these potential arsonists yeah
it's a terrible idea
terrible i shouldn't buy one i don't i
said don't buy this plane thrower don't
buy it
don't buy it that's what i said but
still people bought it
yeah there's nothing that i can do to
staff them yeah it's you build it
i try i said don't buy it it's a bad
idea how many did you make
it's dangerous it's got it's wrong
don't buy it still people bought it i
just couldn't stop them
how many did you make 20 000
and they're all gone in three i think
four days
but it's sold out in four days to a lot
of guys like if you got to choose
between being blind
or having your dick break where your
dick can never get it up again oh
no question what would you say give me
the [ __ ] stick in the dog
give me the stevie wonder glasses
no no no no on the way home we got on
the bus
and while we will wait there my stomach
started hurting
and i said jesus christ i don't know if
i'm going to [ __ ] myself a fart
but let me just take a chance and i blew
this
fart joe rogan that was so bad
right we were on a bus and people
started running you know school buses
people started running to the windows
right to swing down the bus windows
but here's where it gets better i fought
it again
and the teachers were going oh my god
he's changing flavors but
the change in flavor but the worst thing
was the cheerleaders were crying that's
how bad it smelled
they were sitting in front of the bus
going
he's changing flavor one of the teachers
yelled dog
oh my god he's changing flavors that's
how bad these farts were
dude i talked to your buddy eddie bravo
and that guy is a real
he's out there he's like a jet he's like
a deaf like a deaf jack russell almost
you know a deaf
jack russell yeah because once he gets
going you can't oh jack russell terrier
yeah you ever been around one of those
dogs you opened the car and then next
thing you know they're at the yeah
they're like sick yeah but how's he deaf
because you can't get him back
like once he goes you can't you know i'm
saying you can't get him back in the car
like you're sitting there honking the
horn you can't that guy's out there
you know i'm at home you know what i'm
talking about i do know he talked about
but i've never heard anybody make a
description like that a
deaf jack russell terrier my best friend
my father's friend he was sleeping his
wife said you have to go to the dentist
so why he goes your breath is so out of
control
and they've been married for 25 years so
he goes jesus all right so
so check this out this is so apparently
he had an abscess a sack of bacteria in
the back of his mouth
well when they when they i guess took
the tooth out of the filling out
and they popped by accident the sack
the nurse threw up
and the [ __ ] dentist the dennis
walked into the room at that moment
and pulled his mask off and threw the
[ __ ] up as well
no way it was a double vomit fest
so does she puke on him
she didn't pick up she just puked did
they pop the sacks
and the dentist walked in and went he
had his mask and he went
he got to me he got his mask off just
barely
like that yeah oh my god not bad
crazy yeah that's so crazy i never have
the balls to tell someone their breath
stinks
if you work with them if you work with
them you have
that's one cool thing about black people
they'll tell you if that stinks
they will tell you black people have no
problem with that how much flavor flav
she was she would come over and give me
a massage she wasn't very good looking
but she was down to give a massage
by the time you're done with the massage
you know she's going to get to she
wanted to
give me oral pleasure long time ago but
she used her
teeth oh boy and i didn't have the
[ __ ] courage to tell her that i'm
like
i was enjoying it but i was like oh
[ __ ] she's going
here we go
crazy picture you and your underwear
with a tiger on a chain
that is that is one of the that's the
chance right there that's you
at peak crazy yeah insane yeah
what was going through my mind yeah i
didn't know what made me think about
my friend said mike you can get some
awesome animals and i think really are
you serious
i still remember my mother taking me
into a restaurant bathroom
and holding me in the what's that one
headlock
guillotine and she's punching you she
shot you up
yeah what penicillin oh my god because i
my time when i was a kid i was so sick
she got you in the headlock and shot you
better listen to me where'd the needle
go
listen to me top of his head cubans
we had a cuban doctor dr
orlando del valle he made house calls
okay
he came over he would come into the room
and this is very funny because i'm gonna
tell you how
[ __ ] hysterical red x is hereditary
[ __ ] is crazy
your kids get what you got now he would
come over
now dr del valley did a bump from time
to time now this is a great job i'm
talking about i'm talking about 1968
69 please this goes on
him when he come over i lived on 205
west 88th street
he brings a little thing and him my mom
would talk and my stepdad
and then somebody else would be there
like a chick that would help my mom and
sure enough he would come over
put the thermometer in my ass and then
look at me and say jose antonio i have
to give you a needle
and i go give me five minutes let me
think about it
and he and my mom would go what's going
on he has to think about it
i swear to god you don't take that
needle i'll [ __ ] kill you
so then they would go on the [ __ ]
parlor they put on cuban music and i
would like put cartoons on
like it wasn't that ever inevitable and
then he would they would have like two
drinks
like how old are you during this i'm
five six
he would have two drinks and he'd come
back and he goes antonio are you ready
yet
and i'm like i'm not ready so for years
they call me me
that means it's gonna hurt they would
have to hold me down
and give me a shot so then
my stepfather mom the babysitter
and my mom and my mom would be like i'll
[ __ ] knock you out
stop crying you [ __ ] be a man
it's gonna hurt and then it merged into
chip who my girlfriend hated
so much um and chip became the [ __ ]
because they would chip would embarrass
people i did that literally
before i ever thought i'd do on the
radio i would be out with girlfriends
and embarrass them by doing that like we
i'll just be making bad jokes in the cab
and my girlfriend you know uh jen and
even girlfriend would just go just shut
the [ __ ] up
it's not funny and uh
it made me so happy
and what this is what would drive jen
crazy
we'd be in like a really nice steakhouse
and the waiter would come over
and she would order like the salmon and
then chip just goes how much is that
that
would ask the waiter and she was like do
you know how humiliating it
is that people think i [ __ ] that guy
people think i'm [ __ ] this guy
there are no shoes and a [ __ ] and i
get weird they
go through your property you know that
when they process you under jail and so
they pull out a bag of cocaine and they
they re-arrest me at the jail oh my god
so i mean so so i'm in there for like
three days or something
and it's on the news and then the
apartment building's [ __ ] over me
even though i rented
four apartments in the building why
would you rent cause one was a skate
[Laughter]
park
it's two ways it can hit you i do it on
basketball and sometimes
in basketball it's like someone will
throw you a pass and while it's in the
air you go okay what are my options here
when this ball gets to me
i got him cutting i could pass to him i
could
shoot i could pass it back and it's like
all right i'm ready i think i'm right
and then the ball comes to you
and other times that ball just hits you
in the face
[Laughter]
oh sorry guys i was like why are you
playing high it's so
true yeah i i tell a bit on stage i said
something about a big dick man
big dick black man that can't read they
puts it down they help awesome women
they can't read they put it down my
first kid's father couldn't read
when they ain't got no side teeth and
they can't read they got the best sex
cause they practice all the time
black men who can't read don't don't
have sex like black men
who got a nine to five who can't read
their sex is totally different
because they're not tired because they
practice all they do is
practice on women i mean you got my
husband gotta go to work joe he ain't
got time to be flipping me over
slapping me across the head
he got tired of all that ghetto love oh
my god i'm crying
he got tired of all that ghetto go to
the ghetto and buy the weed out of the
other where i live at they would go over
to the ghetto
so i said june how much how much weed
you buy 1.5 grams what the hell is that
i don't know and i called the police on
him
what do you i did i call the police on
to shake him up right
and i you know i called the police on
yeah but i said hey we black so leave
your guns in the car
so come over here and shake my son the
police get over there the police and
junebug son go to school together
this [ __ ] come on and start
crying we love you junebug i said he
called you little [ __ ] cry
now we all cry i was crying
so that didn't help but eventually i
think he's gonna stop smoking now he's
gonna stop or start
i think he stopped i i ran off all his
friends
i told him i said look yo your white son
just lost his only black friend i'm
gonna [ __ ] your white baby up bring him
back over here with the weed
[Music]
you